welcome to chess in the 21st century as
you all know in fact I think you do know
well when other grandmasters do this
class they do it wrong okay because
they're stupid okay
they're not they're not all stupid in
the hill then now they're all stupid
okay so they look at games that were
played in the 21st century ridiculous I
look at games for people who were born
the 21st century the games could have
been played last century I don't care
okay
kids are confused I and the people at
home were like wait a minute
all right now this is subtitle The
Simpsons lecture there's very little
Simpsons would be a lot of blank jokes
and fill in the blank as Trump of course
okay those are all bridge jokes right
like spades and Archer Trump you know
diamonds okay now the first episode of
The Simpsons that was not a Christmas
episode was called let's call a random
person Spencer you know they in the
episode no no that was not the crib what
that's I mean was not Bart the genie is
very good I believe it was 1988 I could
be off by a year but only by a year I'm
off by more than a year I didn't prepare
the Simpsons part of the lecture because
that wouldn't be fair I'll just do it
off the cuff and Bart the genius Bart is
taking a test and doing his usual and
he's getting every question wrong
however he notices Martin Prince
finished the test in like one minute
Martin's the smart kid so Bart took
Martin's paper in a race to Martin in
row Bart Simpson so all of a sudden Bart
was a genius because he put his name on
Martin's paper okay now Bart Simpson
went to a special school for smart kids
because he they thought he had Martin
Prince's answers anyway one of the kids
Walker had a lunchbox and there was a
picture of an old man like Einstein and
it said Karpov on it so that was the
first chess reference of The Simpsons
the first episode
okay and there's many others which we'll
discuss throughout the lecture and then
I'll get funny texts from Lulu and
Spencer okay now what I wanted to do was
talk about girls in chess because we
have a lot of girls here three girls in
the lecture and one coming in right now
I've never I've never seen such a thing
and I knew I knew was going to happen
when I prepared the lecture okay and
we're going to talk about juniors
obviously because it's just the 21st
century and the two juniors I want to
talk about today are anyway and Jennifer
you possibly it's pronounced Wang but
I'll pronounce it Wayne because you know
American well I know our names don't
mean nothing I can't say the actual line
is I'll get in trouble okay but if you
watch pulp fiction which you're never
allowed to do ever then you'll
understand the joke okay now anyway I
believe is 14 but she could be another
age like 13 or 15 and in any case she
was born in this in the centuries that's
all that matters now the games I'm going
to show you were played in the last two
u.s. women's championships this one
Annie was black and her first u.s.
women's against toxify Borromean who's
played in at least 10 US women's
championships I can't show her games
because she wasn't born in the century
so we're not going to look at her moves
we're gonna skip so Ben here's what I
want you to do because chess pace
doesn't work this way every time I make
a move for white to edit that out
because that's cheap she wasn't born in
this century we can't look at her moves
now that's all you a funny story because
it kills time most of my students when I
asked them to show me their games
they're like oh here's the game I played
okay my pawn played here and then I
played this here's why I played this let
my opponent way here and I played this I
put every move their opponent made
they're like yeah whatever and I'm like
did you look at other moves and they're
like what I'm just showing you the game
lemme lon
so people if you want to get better to
look at your opponent's moves
so therefore Bensimon you can't edit it
out you can't do it okay
so Tata EV was white and she played
efore now this is actually very funny
because we have some reverse psychology
here right and Jenna is always saying
that to me I'm always of the chess club
were
working on my chess game doing lots of
chess work doing other people's work and
Jenna's like yo I have some questions
about reverse psychology and I'm like
could you stop I'm working right isn't
that what happened
yesyes she admitted it but you didn't
hear okay and everybody who knows taught
sev will call in a random person Spencer
what does toques have play here with
black she plays the French he's six and
she's made videos on the French now she
she psyched herself out in the last
round of this year's US Women's
Championship good thing Alejandro is not
here or freedo because everybody knew
she was going to play the friends so she
played the Sicilian and then she got
crushed and it cost her the US Women's
Championship and a lot of money
everybody thought she plied the French
well anyway played the French against
Tata who always plays the French and
writes articles it makes videos about it
now in this position anyway who's not a
very tall person therefore she played a
move recommended by short Spencer no
that's a normal move yeah not I think
Nigel played this everybody laughed and
then he won h6 right
okay now h6 is very suspicious the point
of h6 is it puts white on the move and
usually if you want to make a waiting
move here you play either Bishop e7 or a
six if you don't want to make a waiting
move you take on e4 or place five
although I've played nine c6 but that
attacks the pawns that's crazy
and most common move is probably Knight
f6 okay after h6 White has to make a
move now one of the things that white
often does in the French after playing
the movie five is plays f4 and then
moves this Knight to f3 this Knight
doesn't want to be in front of the
bishop so the Knights not going here
unless you're playing into Wednesday
nights then fifty-fifty yeah it's not
going back here so the knight often goes
here so the problem with white play
Knight f3 the most logical move is then
the knight can't other than I can't go
to f3 and the bishop on c1 is blocked so
h6 is a waiting move saying I dare you
to move if white play
the advanced French then why is white
tonight on d2 that's not the best Square
for it
okay so h6 just says I dare you to move
and why did play Knight f3 Knight f6
Bishop d3 of course if black had played
Knight f6 instead of h6
in this position then white would have
play d5 and white doesn't have to play
Knight G f3y can put the other 9 on f3
and the bishop on c1 could eventually
get out so instead of playing a
five-year and wondering what to do with
this Knight white played Bishop to d3
and was hoping that if black takes Y can
take with a knight and then the bishop
on c1 can move now actually h6 makes a
little sense because the bishop can't
really go to g5 again unless it's the
Knights tournament and who knows what
they're doing okay sorry I'm grouchy
about the Knights by just annotated 10
games from the Knights you know that was
a lot of question mark usage there okay
so c5 now if I was white and I was
playing tall shock ed you can look this
guy up on the internet maybe I would
play Queen e2 Lefter c4 I would go oh
hey I did that once the national open I
think it was 2005 but it could've been
1995 it's one of them anyway if you find
the game tall shaked black against me on
the internet I did lose a material that
way so that I resigned okay so Todd Saif
took now everybody in the world takes
for the e pawn but that's why this is
chess of the 21st century because any
took with a knight okay and well these
annotations are by Alejandro which means
they're very suspicious I don't know I
think I think Knight takes is okay okay
castles I think black has a black I
think white he'll edit that out has a
slight lead in development right for is
more than one yeah because black made
this pawn move and black move the knight
twice I made another pawn move and
White's just moving pieces and castling
so obviously white has a better position
Knight to d7 developing a piece a crazy
idea
the problem is what's that that's a
secret it's also a secret for me yeah
there you go yeah okay maybe now the
bishop on c1 would like to get out but
even if it could move then I don't know
where would it go g5 is not good f4 is
not good h6 isn't good
III yeah so this knight defies pretty
good it's keeping this Bishop at bay the
knight is blocking the bishop
so eventually blacks going to catch up
and and take advantage in development
now we talked about the Simpsons in a
long time so this is a good opportunity
because the Simpsons lecture there's an
episode in The Simpsons where they play
putt-putt golf because Homer makes Bart
do it Bart doesn't want to do it but he
has to be rod and or Todd was a rider
Todd Spencer Todd I think it was Todd
anyway so Homer is giving him all kinds
of pep talks you got to beat Todd and so
forth and Bart doesn't want to play
so he's sat in his room and he talks to
Lisa and says Lisa I'm like one of those
pieces in chess that doesn't matter and
Lisa said well a blockaded Bishop is of
little value but I think you're talking
about a pawn okay and as you can see
this bishop which is blockaded for the
moment will eventually be be great this
bishops no great Bishop either so maybe
Lisa was right
okay so 94 unblocking the bishop Caray
Bishop e7 a3 what's the idea of a3
anybody you can raise your hand at home
okay I'm gonna call on you at home no
that's wrong
okay you Luke it prevents night before
probably White was thinking if I place
fourth and I don't go to b4 and try to
take the bishop okay so white played a3
and then that won't happen also a3 is
the mirror image of h6
so black is in Zubaz wong and therefore
resigned class dismissed
on a wait am i didn't make 10 more
Simpsons jokes
okay so black castled and c4c you were
right and as you all know c4 is there
you go that's why you sat close so you
could get that in okay now if this was
the Wednesday class any legal or
Wednesday nights any illegal move is
possible here like 93 93 okay
in fact when we were walking over here
from the from the Kings side we saw a
game in progress where again any move
any legal move or illegal move was
possible okay but these are the finest
players in the country
so black saved her Knight nice okay and
Knight takes e5 not a move I would play
but the point is a3 has another idea
which we're going to find out right now
which is to play b4 and fianchetto our
Bishop so once again White has a lead in
development three minor pieces two to
White has more space on the Queen side
but a favorite Grandmaster of mine who I
haven't heard from in a while
Ilya Gurevich and to go back in the tank
for that one Ilya Gurevich even though
you've never heard of him except for
Spencer was world junior champion so you
should be ashamed and he's American okay
and Ilya once was talking this just a
random guy and I was listening and he
wasn't talking about EF Hutton and how
many you at home were to get there okay
even Spencer and get that so
Ilya Gurevich once told somebody the
pawn structure of four and two notice
there's four pawns there and two pawns
there is better than three and three
and he gave no explanation why but he's
higher rated than me so okay and in my
opinion he's correct the reason he's
correct usually when you have three and
three you have no Center pawns it's good
to have Center pawns as you'll notice
later in the game you'll be like with
Center Park okay so white has no center
pawns and black has the center pawn
which is blocking his bishop so Lisa
wouldn't like that and that explains the
move d6
black wants to play Bishop e7 and
have her bishop developed ok 95 very
aggressive Bishop d7 Queenie to Queen c7
f4 okay and this is what we call a super
aggressive nan a nice giri move on each
curie wouldn't like this move you would
take black here because blacks very
passive okay he would have offered a dry
every move and Tata would decline now
none of that would happen okay
although touch they might decline
alright so f4 playing for an attack on
the Kings side because we can play f5
and our bishops are rolling over here to
the king the Queen can come over here
White's definitely going to a rook lift
or is jenshaw howdy calls it a rover guy
see if you guys are paying attention so
Tata wasn't sure how to improve her game
with pieces so she attacks with pawns f4
were are okay rook FD 8 ignoring
everything now rook FDA would scare me
because f7 is weaker now and in fact
Alejandra wrote I'm not sure the rook
wants to be here keeping the audience
confused guy like that he's maybe a does
but he's not sure and I would actually
say that - because I wouldn't I'm afraid
of my rook away from my kid okay rook a
e1 here comes the attack Bishop to d6
okay so it's funny the bishops are
symmetrically placed d3 and B to be 7
and d6 and the pawn structure is
different White has less puns on the
Kings side but it's still attacking
White has more pawns on the Queen side
but is ignoring that I don't care about
that okay so that's what happened f5 are
ok good annotations he somehow he didn't
write R R okay now one of the problems a
lot of women have in the US Women's
Championship is occasionally they get in
time trouble okay maybe they studied a
Robson's games and they're like oh boy
time trouble that's how I get to 2,700
okay and this game was no exception
now when you get in a time trouble which
the kids are confused about like what's
that mean
okay it doesn't mean you're home late
from school so for example the time
controls 40 moves in some number of
minutes maybe 90 maybe 100 if you're a
normal person and you're a grandmaster
you get into time trouble sometimes you
might have to make four to seven moves
in less than five minutes so you're
moving pretty quickly okay in some of
the US Championships and US women's
championships they get in a horrible
time trouble where you're just moving
really fast now luckily the chess clock
has changed the kids are confused
because they've chest locks been the
same since you've been alive but when I
was alive not now when I was alive okay
we didn't we didn't have this like 32nd
increment and five second delay you just
had whatever time you had so if you had
two minutes on your clock and you had to
make 20 moves good luck now you get 30
seconds and move so nobody cares but if
you have 30 seconds and move every move
and you have to play perfect that's not
easy I mean you can do it but it's not
easy okay so here where I move nineteen
the players are about to get into time
trouble and then they don't play so well
because you can't figure everything out
okay rook e8 x clam because the rook
wasn't well placed on on da it's much
better when your rook is opposing a
queen and it defends ecigs
okay and also it's psychologically very
good first of all she played the French
psyching on her opponent because that's
what taught F plays second she's moving
her rook back and forth it looks like
it's a mistake haha
my opponent obviously made a mistake
when playing rugby eight I have to
punish that mistake if you can't find a
winning line you have to find one anyway
otherwise your opponent played Brittany
you didn't punish her
so Bishop b1 so the Queen can go in
front of the bishop and Queen age seven
mate 94 was the move I was looking at
that's the move alejandra was analyzing
that looks like White has a pretty big
attack here right Knight takes Queen
takes three
in Queen g7 mate Bishop h2 King h1 Queen
g3 defending the mate shocking it's
pretty good defense Queen g7 Queen g7
Bishop g7 both bishops are hanging and
Alejandra says I prefer Y the black is
all right again I don't know what does
he mean okay yeah okay why it's better
but probably a draw so that's what white
should have done but if you analyze a
variation like that and you're like I'm
not winning my opponent lost a tempo my
opponent has black I should be winning
so you try to find something maybe you
don't have okay Bishop b1 always retreat
he takes f5 opening up the line against
the Queen rook takes f5 exciting now I
wonder if the three means she thought
three minutes I was three minutes left
we'll never know I took three seconds to
play rook f5 nice it seems a little fast
okay and then Queen e7 question mark
according to Alejandro and his computer
Knight d7 was the right move putting
tremendous pressure on the night
although hanging the F pawn so now
everything is hanging and pinned
confusing everybody and probably any
looks at 97 and thought it was too
dangerous but if you have a computer
running then you got no problem so when
you see gains between players and
there's a lot of errors and they're like
more precise play then we know nobody's
using a computer okay when they play
perfect every move and you're rated like
1300 very suspicious especially online
those guys online play great okay now
let's get back to the Simpsons because
this is ridiculous why would we talk
about chess with what the Simpsons okay
one time
Bart wasn't in school which makes sense
right and he was giving a simultaneous
in the park in the true story based on a
true story and there was a big crowd
there like wow look at this kid playing
chess he's playing several people at
once then they all checkmated him at the
same time and then unlike his normal
character when they all
check me them he said don't which he
stole from Homer that's not really to
the fair another scene where he's
playing in the park he's playing rabbi
Christoph skis playing hurt
Krusty's father I don't know who won
that game they didn't show the result
I'm assuming Krusty's father could be
Bart
okay back to chess Queenie seven not
playing 97 attacking the pin Knight
Queen c2 now you know why
toxic I've played Bishop b1 here comes
the checkmating attack both sides are in
time trouble and both Kings are exposed
the knight on e5 is pinned everybody's
confused who's the most confused we have
a prize for that anyone now what about
the people at home right they can't even
hear me because they don't know how to
adjust their volume so they're in the
comments
I can hear this I'm too stupid he's my
computer send me a new computer okay
yeah okay that's what they're doing that
too
all right it is true they have good
comments on YouTube like I can't hear
this next I hear it fine well I can't
hear it well I can hear it good really
get in places there yeah yeah it's
amazing they could figure how to write
comments so they can't have the computer
works okay so g6 stopping Queen age 7
million for example it was White's move
rook takes f6 would be annoying because
the Queen's going h7 the Knights going
to g7 scary ok g6 now this lethal
combination is slightly less lethal and
rook F for seeing the rook was attacked
a5 a5 is a very nice move it's not a
nice move because it's a nice move I
don't care about that anybody can be a
good move
ok the reason it's a nice move is that
especially when I'm playing chess or
what I'm showing a puzzle to a student
there had always tilts they decide that
most of the board doesn't matter they're
like hmm ok for example one of the
finest chess players in Michigan
redefine gold she always says that
things are too busy ok she would say
this table is too busy it's got a
computer it's got flowers it has a mouse
it has a phone
- busy doesn't like all that stuff and a
lot of my students they say the same
thing they just don't say that we're
busy they say oh there's too many pieces
I can't solve this puzzle okay so they
take some pieces off the board then they
can solve it all right so the chess
sport has a lot of pieces on the
chessboard is very busy
normally when somebody's mating you and
you're defending you're not thinking of
the move a five so when a five is the
correct move and it has the right
strategical idea that's very hard to
find especially in time trouble so she
took 459 seconds man oh it was hard to
find okay and and the point of a five is
we're attacking everything over here
activating the rook activating the
bishop and most importantly we're
getting the c5 square for the Bishop
Bishop c5 is going to come in very handy
and what's the point on b4 Bishop c5
isn't that very good okay so a5 is
actually an excellent move and in time
trouble white decided to blunder by
playing the move Queen f2 if your
opponent wants to play Bishop c5 these
aren't the right squares for your pieces
okay strategically that's obvious to
everybody but for Tots eV and for many
chess players you're just analyzing
variations and you're like now Bishop c5
that doesn't work then when it does work
you're like man why do I play Queen f2
so the recommendation of the computer is
to retreat the rook back to f1 so we
sort of get rid of this pin on the rook
and then our rook is defending our other
rook
so our knight can move and so forth
right and as Alejandro route it's hard
to play the move rook f1 after you play
the move rook f4 sort of like it's hard
to play the move a5 when everybody's
playing on the Kings side
okay so Queen f2 threatening the night
if the knight moves away we take on f7
and if you defend the night I I wouldn't
do that with the white bishop on b2 no
no don't do that okay so it looks good
you're threatening the night the night
can't be defended then I can't move and
when she played rook f4 obviously her
intention was to double or triple on the
F file
and do some kind of reversed Alekhine's
gun with a twist
okay so black ignored the night by
playing a be very good I want to be
positive about that remark not negative
nothing now very well that's because
we're blood BAM
alright so the truth hurts okay now the
reason black played a be other than
Spencer said so and and gave the night
away was now we have Bishop c5 the
problem with playing f4 f5 and
checkmating your opponent sounds good is
you don't have an F pawn so then when
they attack you on the diagonal you want
your pawn back on f2 but too bad okay
rook takes Knight double question mark
ignoring the opponent king h1 was the
right move although that's tough when
the person is taking your whole Queen
side and she saw Bishop c5 I assume she
had to have seen Bishop c5 because black
just played a V Bishop c5 now what his
white do the ship d4 as suggested by the
audience well according to your
mathematics she did in five seconds so
that means that she saw Bishop c5 and
she was like Bishop d4 no problem this
is the white queen overworked alright
yeah isn't that isn't that some kind of
overwork yeah now there's two things
that I do when I'm playing somebody
really young I play zero theory although
here any played h6 so she took care of
that and there's no tactics it's the
most boring game ever that when my
opponent falls asleep I turn their clock
even though that it's digital now
because I'm old and then their flag
falls and they're like what's a flag and
what's this kids okay so here you see
the queen is overworked just like me
right
you you agree Luke
what do I mean what ah ah alright
see I can't make that joke moving on
okay Bishop D for Queen D for Queen f6
not only is black up material but
White's got nothing White's all pinned
terrible now if you ask many
grandmasters why would white do that why
would white play rook takes f6 and habla
ship c5 there's two reasons one is time
trouble if white thought v ten fifteen
twenty minutes here White's not playing
rook takes f6 but in time trouble
thought 39 seconds thought five seconds
and then you lose all your pieces the
pieces are all defended but one piece is
defending them both so you don't want to
play a tactical melee against somebody
very young because they're good at
tactics what are they good at
strategical chess when they play chess
for one year okay what are they Frank
okay you may get the Frank joke you
that's it Frank's for all right so now
the game is totally over in fact it says
it's truly over annotations by Lionel
Richie exact very good okay a B now I'm
going to be negative about that move
Queen g5 threatening the club you can
get this at home give them about ten
minutes I don't think the audience can
get it what do you think wow you threw
your voice good you sounded just like
iris
okay Queen G to mate g3 that's the
safest King ever rug da attacking the
Queen Queen b6 very suspicious
rookie five and then lots of lots of
nonsense notes from from from Alejandro
now blacks up a rook and all of whites
pieces are horrible okay and threatening
rook takes rook here white resigned or
possibly lost on time probably resigned
after you trade if I can't take this I
lose my rook I have to play as mission
Zerg
doing that and then here the computer
will probably show some force to me
although queen takes rook should win
handily yeah threatening Queenie one
queen bee two rook takes Bishop Queen
that's it queen d4 will be a rook up and
yeah we're going to cup for nothing and
whites getting needed okay
and without those missions look if we
just take the rook like I would do then
then here no no probably black is still
better right because the King's no good
yeah I think black still better but
probably draw okay so that was played by
very young in you that was actually in
last year's championship not this year
now the next thing we're going to look
at is by me I mean by you nice I pay him
no no Jennifer you now of course I
couldn't show the whole game because
that would mean I'm working more and I'm
already overworked from the last game
okay so this is a game played this year
and this was probably the only time in
history where Anna and Irina crush lost
on the same day in the u.s. women's okay
neither one having a good tournament and
Jennifer you was white against Anna and
they were in terrible time trouble which
is good for the audience but bad for the
player but who's more important the
spectator of the players okay and as you
know Anna was involved in some chicanery
earlier many years ago she had a very
funny man sir with Irina crush with no
delay and no increment and they were
both moving in less than one second and
Anna became the US Women's Champion very
suspicious game okay now here we're on
move 40 move forty forty one time
trouble that's everybody's blundering
that's Lulu's only problem I've seen
Lulu play 38 moves perfect and then
inside of troubles who blows it terrible
right there's only one solution for that
crab rangoon yeah no no she agreed yeah
she agreed okay so remember anybody can
try their best I want you to win
let's Homer said that I get so Simpsons
in there
alright so this position has been a back
and forth game White's not doing so
great here
and this position Jennifer played rook
b2b one actually talked I should have
played rook f2f1 it's a rich tapestry
okay and this obviously defends a little
bit more and not too much now let's move
for tea and Anna made a mistake she
should take advantage of the pindy pawn
and play what aggressive move f5 and
after f5 takes takes if we play f4 which
looks good probably why should in play a
five we sacrifice you can't take the
night because rook takes rook check
takes takes this is actually very funny
material is about equal maybe you prefer
white a little material wise but the
beautiful knight on d5 has nowhere to go
very strange usually the knight on d5 is
good here you're going to lose it
also White's King is a little suspicious
and after the move Queen b3 threatening
everything night everywhere check we
play King f8 and surprisingly there's no
defense to the very simple rook da and
in fact in loose game yesterday he could
have taken that D pawn by playing rook
to da and queen c5 alright but that's a
different story and the night is Knights
just trapped on d5 and the computer says
white is completely lost here okay I'm
assuming Anna saw f4 and where their
flag falling didn't want to allow a fork
of a rook at night so she played ripped
six and now f4 doesn't Forker wicked
Knight okay and now we get to move 41
now most people incorrectly believe that
once you get to time control then you
chill out you get some orange juice
you're like oh it's not the time control
I lose BAM you got that right pick it
and then you think for 20 minutes and
you play perfect usually to get some of
41 you're so frazzled by time trouble
you just can't play anymore like you
can't calculate you're not used to going
from 3 seconds and move to 20 minutes
and move and you just play badly so
there's a lot of mistakes I move 41 f4
and now and
made a bad move the correct move is very
hard to play it also takes advantage of
the pin let's call it a random student
Spencer Queen d5x clan that's right it
probably white can draw it's possible
Anna saw everything and she's like I'm
not drawing this game so she decided
losing was better I've made those
decisions myself okay so it takes takes
takes takes okay
and now rookie three and after Queen f1
which is four so you don't lose the H
pawn
d3 and every move is forced every moves
double X clam takes D - all right and
white has one move that doesn't lose
here I can't oh I can do this yeah what
if he does a king aged to ins to the
king f2 was considered worse I think
because of rookie 3
yeah the computer the computer didn't
like King H - but I have no idea why I
actually looked at it but then I was
working so hard I forgot King up to
slightly better than King H - slightly
actually you'll see why in a second ok
now what's the only move for Wyatt
resign the positions should be a draw
but White has one move it seems to me if
I had black and I saw this I would I
would do it because black has it as a
White has trouble finding the right move
now this isn't easy
yeah probably she just thought I'm not
sacking my Queen I'll just win later but
there was no leader what's that
no then I play rook e1 check and Queen
dish ábeforeá it's only move yeah and
then blacks better but probably a draw
okay so that was the correct way of
playing and it's possible Anna saw if
she played Queen d5 that a draw was
likely and she thought I'm not drawn
this game I got to win so she retreated
her Knight e5 yeah now blacks key isn't
that very good because White's advancing
her pawns looking on d5 is great than on
h7 is terrible now White has a big
advantage
okay so Queen b8 we're treating the
Queen and after g5 very interesting move
white made a very strong move here which
takes advantage of pawn moves okay so
Bart Simpson desk
I'm upon when you move a pawn you can't
move it backwards it's true although
actually when I saw the game outside
when we came here okay so the move g5
does two things that are bad it gives
squares away that we're defended and it
gives away this diagonal so white takes
advantage of that by playing Bishop
efore yeah that's an annoying move if
the plum is on g6 that would be much
less annoying I would tell my student
here to play g6 now they look at me
funny but I still take their check in
cash it
okay Queen d8 which doesn't defend the
knight but it attacks white tonight in
return if you do take it that's actually
a good move King f1 and the zukes Wang
King f1 is a good movie actually because
it defends the rooks and more
importantly it gets off this diagonal so
there's no d3 check which would be bad I
tried to show you games where black has
a Bishop on c5 and white has a king on
g1 except this time White's King moved
to f1 instead of getting crushed King f1
what's the problem okay rook h6 Bishop
takes Knight Queen takes obviously if
rook takes h7 Knight f6 is annoying
always retreat and f5 okay now here the
computer says whites up plus one plus
1.5 if Fabiano is here and I just talked
to his parents earlier he would be like
what White's crushing black rock okay
because blacks position is terrible the
rook on h6 doesn't make any sense this
Bishop is a blockaded Bishop I'm
advancing my majority terrible okay and
here Anna uncharacteristically blundered
I cannot explain this blunder I don't
know what she was thinking I don't think
she was in time trouble yet you get in
time trouble again and one of the
reasons this is a blunder is when your
opponent lets you take something for
free you should be like hmm why did they
do that and if you're playing tactically
against a young player like Jennifer you
who was the world's youth champion for
her age they're probably not making big
tactical mistakes strategically
positionally and with their experience
and I could try to slowly outplay
Jennifer but not on one move tactic the
Jennifer is too good and she played rook
takes e5 a terrible blunder iris is
shocked this game was played only a few
months ago I'm sure I always remembers
with refutation was Bishop c6 yeah I
knew that and now we're attacking
everything I have no idea what and I
didn't see Jesus didn't see Bishop c6
and that's not good now we're attacking
everything and that that's that's about
it okay rook e3 nom-nom-nom and then
black played down a rook but whites up a
rook so yeah not good being down a ruck
and okay after being down a rook for
quite a long time and now losing the d4
pawn ah Spencer girls I'm talking about
I lost by d4 walking out of resign yeah
sensor really knows what I'm talking
about man if only he knew if only you
knew what we knew
you know you'll never know you'll never
you don't want to know we know horrible
so those were two good games by two of
America's young stars anyway and
Jennifer you and he's playing right now
in Soviet Russia where chess plays you
although it's any win that you so anyway
annie has five out of seven as we speak
will you guys watch the video at home
you'd be like no she doesn't
she has seven hundred nine okay well
you'll see it in two or three days so I
hope you like my lecture better than the
other Grand Master who did a lecture
yesterday Grandmaster Ken West yeah he
did yeah and I asked the funny question
I said how much does kind of let's get
paid for doing a lecture and the answer
is who knows the answer there's an
actual answer I'm not this isn't a joke
everything else was a joke very close
one month membership to the Chess Club
okay so I hope you liked my Simpsons non
Simpsons lecture chess the 21st century
go USA we're going to win a lot of
medals in Russia so but we're the best
all right I hope you enjoy the
festivities I hope you had a lot to
drink before you came here especially
the kids and I hope you have a lot to
drink at home I'm out